on n'a pas le choix de verdir parce
qu'on le voit on a repoussé la nature
des villes et là on a plein de problèmes
de santé publique et d'environnement on
peut plus fonctionner comme ça ça c'est
des pensées là anciennes
[Musique]
un des merveilleuses exemples de
végétalisation du bâtiment mais c'est
les la tour de Bosco à Milan c'est une
forêt verticale on a conçu la banquise
pour avoir une multitude de balcons et
avoir une forêt sur chaque étage
c'est fantastique et c'est un exemple
d'architecture qui intègre parfaitement
le végétal au bâti et on le voit c'est
entouré d'édifices à peine végétalisées
et en plein milieu d'un quartier on a
cette forêt là qui est jaillit et on
devrait en faire beaucoup plus
[Musique]
il y a trop de surfaces bétonnées en
ville il faut végétaliser les villes
puis souvent on pense pas qu'on peut
végétaliser facilement les murs il y a
toutes sortes de façon qu'on peut
végétaliser les murs on peut les
végétaliser avec des câbles on peut
faire pousser des plantes sur des
grilles on peut accrocher des caissettes
sur les murs ça prend presque pas de
place au sol donc les murs végétalisés
sont sous-utilisés en ville il faut
vraiment leur accorder plus important
avec les plantes grimpantes il y a comme
une légende urbaine que le grimpant va
fondre un mur abîmer la maison si on a
un mur de brique on a un mur de pierre
oui si les joints sont effrités en
mauvais état la plante peut contribuer
un petit peu à l'effritement mais si les
joints sont en santé il y a aucun aucun
problème
l'impact que peut avoir des temps de
grimpantes sur la qualité de l'air et
son nombreux on peut abaisser la
température donc les gens vont être plus
confortables les murs vont également
permettre de capter les poussières en
abaissant la température on va avoir
également un effet sur la climatisation
du bâtiment ça va être moins énergivore
les plantes contribuent également à la
gestion des eaux pluviales un mur après
une pluie va boire de l'eau va évaporer
de l'eau c'est également de l'eau qui va
être consommée sur place il y a toutes
sortes de grimpants il y a des grimpants
comestibles il y a des grimpants qui
vont fleurir qui vont contribuer à la
biodiversité donc il faut être
imaginatif avec les grimpants
végétaliser les villes et un impact là
c'est certain sur la qualité de la
qualité de l'eau la qualité également là
des sols mais il y a un impact également
sur l'humain
[Musique]
la biophilie c'est l'amour quand les
humains l'homme lui-même pour ce qui est
naturel donc dès qu'on est en présence
des éléments naturels entre autres les
plantes à ce moment-là ça nous apaise ça
réduit le stress ça n'a un impact
vraiment positif sur notre bien-être
donc c'est un outil de plus pour
favoriser la santé mentale des
populations urbaines
moi je rêve de passer un avion au dessus
des villes et qu'on ne voit rien qu'on
voit juste des végétaux que la ville a
vraiment été intégrée à la nature et
qu'on peut vivre l'humain et
toutes les formes de vie ensemble
[Musique]